told you we're in oh now it's the zombie
a bit of hide though [ __ ] this is tricky
part I don't want to [ __ ] this up tight
here
I hate this sound so [ __ ] much
the darkness I guess huh
[Music]
so clearly how there is I think that's
where I need to go though but he will
chase me that's somewhere smart
oh [ __ ] this is sneak pass I'm holy [ __ ]
actually list this run for it
[Music]
[Applause]
that sound gives me goosebumps I'm not
Oh someone
[Music]
okay so my guess is that he knows where
I am I found on the water if someone
gave me a tip and said watch out for the
water
but I still feel I'm [ __ ] either way
actually here's a barrel though I could
jump up at an eye
I don't know it doesn't really make any
sense but let's find the leopard for now
it's awesome I can steam whenever I want
[Applause]
right there
yeah it's fine when I pick it up it's
when I open it
I think I read that already
where do I hide though and when he shows
up
I don't get that part
and I don't want to replay this I guess
I guess he's coming from there something
or there
what if I just run out of here yeah
that's probably the best thing
yeah definitely
[ __ ] I hate that [ __ ] sound
let's just wait for now I guess
bad enough right now much more
[Music]
however the [ __ ] can you be everywhere
was there a [ __ ] second ago
let's make the food sound
all this good necklace a clear
[Music]
oh yeah wasn't that from back
yeah it seems like the Sun won't stop so
which means I have to run yeah
oh I can hold the ham
[Music]
I shoulda never mind that
[Music]
[Applause]
this is so bad
so bad he won't Schatzi - that's it best
[ __ ] party
[Music]
let's go home no one likes you
Wow
Kilis one for you
frustrate never mind never mind
are there is a C's hand
holy [ __ ] I'm glad I didn't Rasta
let's go all
[Applause]
oh there is
[Music]
how the [ __ ] am i what the penis
ami doesn't found me
maybe that's just something I
let's try
[Music]
a Mississippi doesn't like
are they is Pakistan
oh there is a stump there all right
let's go now that
[Music]
okay so over there now
Oh penis penis penis I don't
[Music]
where
[ __ ] tell me where
[Music]
[Music]
please don't find me please don't find
me I've done it never never ever no no
no oh I hope he doesn't know however
this work
[Music]
it's such a [ __ ] difference if you
don't I
Oh
[Music]
but in Locke
okay the sound can stop please thank you
[Music]
oh yeah that was cogwheel pusle and
other rooms gives any dog wheels I can't
pick it out for ya
right
[Music]
is he coming in
sounds like it
[Music]
it's a [ __ ] nightmare hurry up
you found me in this room the last time
that did not sound well that's it
well
oh please [ __ ] you see you later bye bye
[ __ ] this game [ __ ] this game this game
this is so [ __ ] stressful I can't say
that I ate I'd have to go in an hours I
have to finish that's
[Music]
what should i do I don't keep laying I
can't even tab hours because I'm gonna
tap out the it locks the entire [ __ ]
computer I can't do [ __ ] I'm so [ __ ]
Jesus Christ